- Are you and Penny hosting,
do y'all host family for the holidays?
- Well, my family is so big.
I got eight kids.
- Wow.
- So the- one minute,
there's two in the house
and there's a two over here.
Two of them live in Los Angeles,
- Yeah.
- Four live in England and
all- we're gonna try, though.
- Okay.
- We're gonna try and get them together.
- Is that nuts?
Oh my gosh.
That's a lot of- well,
that's a lot of love.
- That's the clan.
- Yeah.
- Little clan.
- That's a- yeah, well Christmas-.
- We're all worn out now.
- (laughs) From being around each other?
- That's what happens if you
haven't got a television.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah. (laughs)
So wait, this is Rod
preparing for the holidays.
You posted this.
So this is two years ago at dinner.
(bells ringing)
- You're probably
wondering why Rod Stewart
is peeling potatoes this Christmas.
Well, we're all gathered here in Florida.
There's not never some,
we've all been given a job.
Mine is peeling potatoes,
while we do one, thank you all
for making this a wonderful
Christmas with the new album.
Two weeks in the chart at number one.
Thank you so much, Merry Christmas.
Back to the potatoes.
(audience laughing)
- I should have expected that to be shown.
- I mean, wait, wait.
(applause)
Two things.
One, congratulations on
the hat, it's remarkable.
How did it work?
It just kept going on-
did it just constantly, or
every time your jaw moves,
like what was happening?
- I just had a battery in it.
- Okay, great.
Okay, well, I have so many jokes here.
Um, so are, are you always-?
- Oh go on then, tell us one of them.
- No, daytime.
(audience laughs)
- Oh, I got it, I see
where you we're going-.
- Where did you steal them from?
(laughs)
- You are a naughty girl.
- No!
No.
- She's naughty.
(cheers and applause)
- No.
Are you, it's a-. (laughs)
- It never even crossed my mind.
- Mine either, you perv.
Are you always on potato peeling duty?
Is this your job?
- No, no, no.
- Oh, no?
You just got excited about it?
- I don't mind doing the
dishes when we haven't got,
when our chef's not working
and Penny cooks dinner.
- Yeah.
- I make sure all the
kids help with the dishes,
I'll help with the dishes.
- Yeah.
I'm the cleaner, okay, I love cleaning.
- I love doing dishes.
My sister loves cooking.
I'm like, I don't want to cook,
but I will clean any dish.
- Yeah.
- It's easier, yeah.
And I'm anal, I like being-.
- It's a riveting point, wasn't it?
- Yeah-
(audience laughs)
so exciting this interview
right now. (laughs)
It's just riveting.
So wait, speaking of holidays,
weren't you once banned
from all Holiday Inns.
'Cause I find this very rock and roll.
- Oh yeah, there's a-.
- What did you do?
- Oh, you know me, we did it.
(laughs)
It was a, it was in the
early seventies, we,
yeah, we'd smash up hotels.
I know it sounds idiotic,
but we were treated so badly,
you know, by the staff and
the- usually Holiday Inns,
that we smashed up a hotel and,
paid the bill.
But then we checked in as
Fleetwood Mac in the next hotel.
(laughs)
(audience laughs and cheers)
Because they weren't well known.
- Oh my God.
- When the faces of Fleetwood
Mac was still coming up.
- Oh my god, that's amazing.
Oh we've got Sir Rod
Stewart here, give it up.
(audience cheers)
His new album is called
the Tears of Hercules,
and it is out now.
It's a rad title, by the way.
Why did you name the title
that, why did you have-?
- Well, it's one of
the songs on the album.
And it is to point out that men,
strong men, tough man can cry.
- Absolutely.
Well later you'll be singing
a song called One More Time.
So what's that about?
- Well, you know when you
split up with the girlfriend.
- Yes.
Well, no but-.
- And the sex was good.
(audience laughs)
- Well, I'll put on my imagination hat.
- When you split up with your boyfriend
and the sex was exceptional,
but that's all you, all you
we're going out with him for.
- Okay, yes.
- And you split up, and
say we'll just do it,
well upstairs one more time.
- Oh.
(audience cheering)
This is a great idea.
This is a great idea
for a song, that's real.
You're like, I was there
for this, but yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then it's kind of fun,
then it's like the red
button like you shouldn't do.
- Yeah, shouldn't do it.
I've never done it myself.
Have you?
- Liar. (laughs)
- On Simon, I have never done it.
- I've never done it.
- Just like one more,
you know, (indistinct)
(laughs)
- Wait, that was amazing,
I want it to be a GIF.
There's a special song
on the album, though,
and it's called Touchline.
- Yeah.
- So what's, what's this about?
- Well, I've played soccer-
football all my life
and I was a pro once,
but cut a long story short, my dad,
where there were three of us, three sons.
- Yeah.
- And we all played football
and he was the manager
of the team and he was a
good player in his day too.
So he managed the team and
that's in there, it's amazing.
- Yeah.
- Long time ago, and he'd
pick the team and he'd
always be on the touchline,
pouring the rain,
snow, shouting at us, abuse
and everything like that.
And we loved him for it, you know,
but then of course he passed on.
- Yeah.
- And the song's all
about how I find myself
doing the same thing with my boys.
On the touchline, watching
my sons playing football.
- I love that.
- And hopefully, when I'm gone,
they'll do exactly the
same with their sons.
So it's a very, it's a
manly sort of, sort of song.
- Well, and it's cool though,
because not all men show up
for games for their kids.
- Yeah absolutely.
- That's amazing.
- And I think we call it the sideline.
So it's the touchline?
- Yeah, touchline in football,
sideline is in your football.
- Okay, okay, right on.
Well, that's all,
that's about all I know about
sports ball, right there.
- That's okay, darling.
- (laughs) Sideline.
- Let's move on quickly.
- Let's move on quickly. (laughs)
You are loving this interview, okay.
So this year marks the 50th
anniversary of Rod's album
Every Picture Tells a Story,
(audience member cheers)
which- okay, yes ma'am.
(audience cheers)
You got a grown.
It tells a story which
features the hit, Maggie May,
which everyone knows, now
I love that song so much.
It's an amazing album,
obviously you got some fans.
But I do want to talk
about a favorite of mine.
And this is not, I told you in the break,
this is, I'm on tour.
You know, you're always on tour
and you're in different cities, right?
Well, I was in Seattle,
(audience member cheers)
and they usually have really
great record stores there,
like vinyl and I've always loved vinyl.
Like, since I was a kid,
it's like the one thing that
was passed down to me in my
family from my grandmother.
So I love vinyl.
And I was in this store and I found,
It's Never a Dull
Moment, it's your record.
And I think it's from like
the seventies, but it had,
I noticed and why I picked
it up, I was like, ooh,
I love Rod Stewart, and then
I was like, oh he covered
I'd Rather Go Blind, I love that song.
And then it turns out it's
literally one of my favorite
covers of any song that
anyone's ever done.
Not just your voice, the production,
like whoever put that to-
it is so tasteful and so beautiful.
And I'm wondering, 'cause
it wasn't like full of them.
So why did you pick that
song for that record?
- Well,
Etta James did it first.
- Yes, yeah.
- And then the girl out
Fleetwood Mac did it,
but it wasn't a big hit.
What's her name, Stevie, not
Stevie Nicks, the other one.
- I do know Stevie Nicks-
oh you mean (stammering)
- The other one.
- She wrote Songbird.
Yep, I'm Blanking.
- Yeah me too, anybody know?
Not Stevie, the other girl.
- [Audience] Christine.
- Christine!
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
- Christine McVie, she did
it and I heard her do it.
So I decided to do it.
- Yeah.
- But- and it was an after thought,
I was in the studio with
Ronnie Wood, you know,
Ronnie is (indistinct) with The Stones.
And we had nothing to do.
And we said, let's have
a go at Rather Go Blind.
We had three bottles of wine
and we did it in two takes.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, I was-.
- Two takes.
- I was literally gonna
ask you if that's what-
(audience claps)
I feel like, the two things
I love for my career,
it was literally just like so easy.
- Yeah, yeah.
It flowed so easy.
- Like, we didn't work at
it, it wasn't over-produced.
- Yeah.
- And it was just like the moment.
That's what it sounds like.
- Yeah, that how it was.
- Yeah.
- People love it.
- So lesson learned, I just got
to have two bottles of wine,
and record some music (audience laughs)
and it'll be magical.
So is it true that you and
Ronnie are back in the studio?
You were just talking about Ronnie Woods,
so are y'all back in?
- Yeah, yeah.
Ronnie has been spending
a lot of time digging up
a lot of old Faces stuff
from the early seventies.
- Yeah.
- And we were putting
it all back together.
It was about 60 odd tracks.
- Wow.
- And I said, Ronnie, don't sing,
I can't sing in the same key, you know.
- Change the key.
- We, well I suppose we could.
Yeah, but that'd be cheating, wouldn't it?
- No.
- Because you have to rerecord it again.
- No, God, in my female time of the month,
I lower those songs.
(audience laughs)
My vocal chords are
doing different things.
- Well no, the songs,
have you found any you
did in the seventies?
- Nope, I was not a thought yet.
- No you weren't a singer then, we're you?
(laughs)
- I was born in '82.
- Ah, wish I was dead.
(laughs)
- Nope.
(audience cheers)
- I'm still jet lagged.
- No, no, but I would have
been amazing in the seventies.
I feel like I missed my time.
Might I suggest though, wine?
'Cause y'all did really
well with wine before,
you and Ronnie.
- Yeah.
- So might I suggest some wine?
- Good idea.
- Maybe you'll hit some
notes again there. (laughs)
So how do you keep your
voice strong, though?
This is one thing I ask
vocalists all the time.
'Cause it's different for all of us.
- Yeah.
- And we all have different ranges.
- Well, the older you get,
it's like being an athlete,
you really got to look
after only two muscles,
that bang together.
- Yeah, boo boo boo boop, yeah.
- So you've just, they've
got to rest, tons of water,
not too much caffeine,
plenty of sleep and a
warm up and warm down.
- Yeah, I'm good at all of
that except for caffeine.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I love coffee and tea.
- Yeah, and I just refuse.
I'll just sound like
Janis Joplin, it's fine.
- Jan, what a singer she was.
- Exactly, it was quite a career.
- She used to chase me and
Ronnie around the room,
trying to get into our trousers.
(audience laughs)
- She was trying to get-
she was trying to get one more time?
- Yeah.
- Or was there ever a first? (laughs)
No, I love that.
So wait for- I heard that Frank Sina-
I actually heard that about Janis Joplin.
I'm like you crazy Texas chick.
Okay.
But Frank Sinatra gave
you advice one time,
which is amazing to say,
that was amazing to say.
- He said pack it up.
- What, what is that?
- Pack it up, he said, you- no, seriously,
his daughter is the
godfather for some of my kids
and I met him a few times.
- Oh.
- And he gave me this advice
for singing, you know,
sing underwater, swim lens underwater.
- Oh.
- I do it with a brick as well, you know,
because it expands your
lungs so you can get more
air capacity.
- Swimmers have so much,
such great lungs, yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's true, that's true.
Okay, well everybody get in the pool.